Hogwarts Legacy just dropped a brand new
launch trailer and I've been told it's
the best one yet they were hyping it up
last night whoa whoa whoa wait a second
hold up hold up hold up there's two new
trailer there's two new wait The
Wizarding World dropped the trailer too
okay we're gonna react to both of them
so guys let's dive in one last time
before the launch of Hogwarts Legacy
okay two minutes 28 seconds here guys
the official launch trailer of Hogwarts
Legacy in light of your unique
joining us a fifth year who's this
talking buys something extraordinary to
ensure your success
is that Weasley Maybe
a lot to absorb on your first day oh my
gosh can't believe I'm here
I can't either Weasley has asked that
your professors give you instruction
outside of the ordinary curriculum
oh my goodness you have the benefit of
an exceptionally skilled team of witches
and wizards to guide you man
a surprised opponent is a weaker Queen
they will test your abilities both
olivanders and learn you've done it a
boy D how much time the new fifth year
seems to be spending away from the
castle no need for theatrics I'm only
here for this one anyway what do they
want from students I have a rare ability
to see Whispers of ancient Magic
the book there's the book The Path we're
on is terribly dangerous
but I do not know where
[Music]
there's the troll again
oh
oh my gosh this looks so good
High wing
dude look at that
all right we got a sneak peek at that
the dragons already
[Music]
oh the music dude
let's even hurt shall we
oh yeah
we leave our Legacy in your hands
what
we leave our Legacy in your hands and
that was that was both black and Weasley
there oh my goodness you guys I can't
believe this I can't believe we're this
guy it's next week man it's next week
all right so the Wizarding World trailer
is three minutes long let's go ahead and
check out what they have to say here
turn up a little bit we're nearly there
yes we are
oh oh
no the feels man
Ollivander
very curious
oh my gosh the music fancy one last deep
dive well sure let's do this unique
situation the start of the trailer we
are told
I'm thinking that's Weasley too it
sounds like Weasley
[Music]
an enchanted book yet the Wizards Field
Guide
wow that's your Wizard's Field Guide
James your house kind of hear his voice
this is during gameplay allowing us to
catch up on our magical education right
because they had to explain that somehow
and this we still don't know why we
started the fifth year
Professor garlic yes alongside a glimpse
of classmates pulling mandrakes
oh yeah
ouch ouch
[Music]
don't neglect your ear muffs not just
herbology we see in the trailer
Professor with only one arm Conjuring
what appears to be a unicorn Professor
Weasley performs Transfiguration
great great grandmother of Ron Weasley
there we go
[Music]
instruction outside of the ordinary
curriculum some work to do outside of
our normal lessons yeah I mean because
we gotta get caught up somehow
now they're going to set the vivarium
yep
we need more deep come on
we need a we need to see way more of
Deke outdoor air where you can keep a
nurse romantical creatures right we knew
this
that looks insane right there who are
they what are they either way we don't
want to get on the wrong side of them I
mean it looks like
are they fighting the Goblins too or
were the Goblins terribly dangerous
guiding it
yes the Knights of Hogwarts
oh my gosh cutting to the movies like
this was such a nice touch
yeah this is the part we get to play
this is the part we got to play
inner managers do all this are
desperately trying to figure out what
breed this is
we know what breed it is a pretty and
black pretty and black
now this I think touches on
that what seems to be the core plot of
the game this ancient magic whisked off
to do extracurricular activities and
maybe even why we started Hogwarts as a
fifth year there it is we knew it was
connected to that we still need more
though big responsibility on their
shoulders
don't get too cozy
dude
oh my gosh the way they cut in with the
movies right there
right in the fields this is happening
you guys it is actually happening 20
years 20 years we've waited for this so
quite a few of the scenes that you saw
in that trailer right there I actually
had a chance to experience and play
firsthand if you haven't checked out my
Impressions yet I'll post them on the
right side of the screen now guys we
have so much Hogwarts Legacy content
planned in the works and already on the
channel so be sure to subscribe if you
haven't already thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon